herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
video leute noch bin ich hier alleine
aber gleich hole ich mir sebastian und
luca und werde ihnen beiden jeweils neun
fragen stellen an denen ich herausfinden
möchte wer von den beiden mich besser
kennen ich habe extra fragen gewählt bei
logischerweise sebastian kennt mich
schon mein ganzes leben und luca er
sieben oder acht jahre oder so
deshalb habe ich halt fragen gewählt die
beide gleichermaßen beantworten können
sollten ich kenne ihn gleich einfach die
fragen und werde ich ihnen die fragen
stellen wenn immer nur einer im raum
sein so dass der andere nicht die
antworten mithören kann die richtig sind
und wir gucken dann gleich einfach mal
wer von den beiden mich besser kennen
legen wir los
so leute da ist luca einmal bitte
klassen also bastian herzlich willkommen
im heutigen video und hat luca weber
gehen direkt mit der allerersten frage
sehr einfach vom zum einen von anfang an
habe ich geburtstag
thun wechselt in die gasse direktor 24
790 richtig gerade bei moritz genau der
ersten frage sollte ein leichtes sein
wann habe ich geburtstag
du kannst ja 1912 berlin klar
zweite frage welche kleidergröße trage
ist das heißt einer größe sowie ml mit
dem song etwas sind zwei größen beides
frage ja im moment wird was m und ein
bisschen was heißt jetzt vielleicht so
normal
und dann ich bin zu müssen welche
kleidergrößen tragen zwei stück m und l
luca auch gesagt fakt ist also kein
einziges lied gehört haben wieder ein
feld nur entwickelte smart ihr guckt
bericht land und allein verlag jugend
luca sagt sagte grammatik glück hat auch
gesagt dass du es ja bestimmt wissen
wird weil irgendwelche sachen trägt zb
meine hose an
fragen mal 3 was ist meine
lieblingsklamotten marke bzw
die marke die ich am meisten frage
[Musik]
ich wollte sagen du hast das gerade
interessieren wird überlegt eigentlich
trägt oft voll auf kitsch einfach vom
forst über ihr fahrzeug
welche ist meine lieblingsklamotten
marke das müsste dann glaube ich new
york city 21
es gibt jetzt moment war ich glaube
alles schwierig alternative deutscher
außenpolitik
das sollte das schon klappen den
treibstoff tabak des neuen lieblingswein
darauf kommt also sea fire ich einfach
ein kurzes jedes einzelne teil was die
fertigung kohls nicht so ne harke oder
so was mache ich eigentlich auch ganz
gerne
von daher ist auf jeden fall meine
verbrennt wir dumm von mir wissen sagt
man habe ich meine erste wohnung kann
ich schon mal so viel sein es ist noch
nicht so lange her
so konnte wissen dass sowieso aber
seitdem ich in köln wohnt habe ich
sozusagen meine erste eigene wohnung
kommt es auf genaue datum an also keine
schätzung ab was zu groß ist richtig
januar wachst du richtig ist fünfzehnter
januar aber es ist relativ nah dran muss
man sagen das ist krass
seit wann habe ich meine erste wohnung
auf den tag genau das auf den tag genau
also ich war wenn ihr gewinnt ok am 15
februar für twitter januar als speaker
doch weil du kannst du kannst 15 jahren
angepasst ja aber du hast das ist sicher
weniger seitdem dort viel besser
diagnose fünfzehnter
ja klar ich habe trotzdem ich habe
geschrieben als ich die schlüssel
bekommen habe und so habe ich in die
familien gruppen und so geschrieben also
könnt das schon wieder die nächste frage
ziemlich schwierig weil eigentlich passt
es so gar nicht zu mir
und zwar was war die letzte sportart
aktiv betrieben habe
spot genutzt man glaubt es kaum also
etwa ganz unernst die letzte sportart
betrieben das war glaube ich dass wir
beiden im fitnessstudio beim er weist
vereinssport gemeint minikicker fußball
mit ok nächste frage
so kann muss er lachen was war die
letzte sportart die aktiv betrieben
hatte verein sport vereins wurde als der
letzte verein sportarten schwimmen
korrekt also ist das eine frage die du
definitiv auch beantworten kannst und
zwar wie es unsere fußball mannschaft
auch so eine sache die vereint und das
ist glaube ich 2012 gewesen dass wir den
fußball mannschaften bei so einem
turnier alter für abfüll keine ahnung
gar keine ahnung dass weder die
mannschaft endlich gewalt hinter drin
oder oder was ich weiß noch wie diesen
hat ihm unbekannt 40 millionen unique
wer das gesagt was wahr ist ein video
von tally comedy auf jeden fall ein
bootcamp video unbekannte videos unsere
fußballmannschaft aus will dieser
besondere eine die uns alle verbunden
hat
minute luca hatte keine ahnung keine
aber du warst hat mich sogar noch
korrigiert sein defektes 11 punkte jetzt
ist wieder geschäfts frage wie groß bin
ich auf den zentimeter genau
[Musik]
ich würde sagen 186 1 89 wenn ich meine
person aber 16 und 18 jahre kommt auf
jeden fall in dieser stilrichtung
gespannt was ihr was zu sagen wie groß
wenn ich auf den zentimeter genau 1 88
19 80 euro aber luca höchst über müsse
der zentimeter gewachsen
eine person steht schon die nächste
frage bezieht sich wieder auf größere
ich muss halt immer so ein bisschen
oberflächlich fragen stellen weil das
für mich kein anderes ist also schon
mein ganzes leben des verwehrt ein
bisschen unfair welche schuhgröße habe
ich sie herzlich
46 weiter an einen schuh habe ich auch
740 du kriegst dass alles korrekt 44
dankeschön welche schuhgröße habe ist du
hast ungefähr meine größe was natürlich
nicht dass ich dann dass wir nicht wie
sonst aus mit seinen 564 45 hast du also
44 x 1440 halb sechs und vierzehn hall
aber keinen scheiß ich habe in allen
meinen schuhen sechsten wird mindestens
46 war kein scheiß doch ich glaube doch
da präsentiert den halb genommen hat 640
und diese mannschaft in den ecken und
für zigaretten zum beispiel hässlich
siebente und letzte frage luca welche
augenfarbe habe ich würde ich habe mir
ein freund vorgestellt 10 nochmal die
aus welcher und was habe ich gedacht ist
es so schwierig
du kannst es nicht sagen oder wir uns
gestern nach den ganzen abend über über
augenfarben unterhalten als wir männer
förderungen deswegen damit auf das level
brown hat und du aufbauen und die
allerletzte frage man lieber es welche
augenfarbe hatte
je stärker größer du eine ganz tolle
farbe dienst nämlich braun leichten
grünstich immer braun korrekt wird ein
ganz bisschen grüner jäger heute
funktionär ich hab' ich habe brown
angesetzt als augenfarbe deshalb ich
bedanke mich bei dir wir sehen uns
gleich eine and cut wieder danke ich den
gewinner verkündet ich verkündige dass
sebastian mit 0,1 punkten vorsprung
gewonnen habe meine augen braucht mit
dem kleinen das hörvermögen drei
verschiebung das team man etwas zusammen
gearbeitet und ich wäre auch wer auch
nicht ohne mein team
da kurz das war's dann auch von
sebastians worten ich hoffe dass wir
euch gefallen hier finden abonnieren
-button da können wir drauf klicken und
mich abonnieren und hier findet ihr ein
eigenes video ich hoffe dass sie dadurch
gefallen lassen
sabonis abonnieren
[Musik]